so dilson tell me what motivated you to
create these instructional modules for
online learning so my course principles
of computing as you know is a course
introductory computer science course for
non-majors and most of my students have
a steep learning curve sure so any
additional resource outside of lectures
that let them engage with the material
at their own pace is very beneficial and
the instructor before me had developed
some online resources in the form of oil
I modules oil I open learning initiative
platform of CMU and these modules you
can think of as units of online material
and the typical way we use them was to
ask the students to complete complete
one module before coming to the lecture
view their progress and identify that
the challenges that they are having a
nun tailored the lectures accordingly
and I thought that this was a pretty
promising approach and I wanted to
develop my own material with a richer
set of activities including programming
activities so that the program's could
get automatically executed by the
platform and the students could get
feedback on and there's one more reason
I I wanted to do this and because I
thought it was a good opportunity for me
to develop myself as a teacher I know
that developing material with oil I
makes you interact with people with
pedagogical expertise like people like
you from the Eberly Center and I thought
this would also be a good learning
experience for me well thanks i think
it's interesting that a lot of faculty
are hired for their role as educators
based on their research and expertise in
the discipline
but they may not be expert in pedagogy
or they may not have a lot of experience
creating online instructional resources
so we're happy to help work with subject
matter experts such as yourself and help
them to create the most effective online
resources but also make that an engaging
process for you as an educator and sort
of learning more about your students
learning process and you're not alone
either in any given year the Carnegie
Mellon faculty represents a little over
a thousand people teaching CMU courses
each year and we at the everly center
work with about one and three of those
faculty members so we're happy to help
as we have I think in this case with the
oli modules for your course yeah thank
you you advised me all along you know
about getting my learning objectives
clear and aligning my activities and
assessments with those objectives I
really learned a lot in the process so
one thing I'm curious about is how you
think your students experience has
changed from before you had these oli
modules to now when students can work
with the oli modules right I think it
really changed for the better for
example my first lecture on programming
used to be hard both for me and for the
students because I had to start with
some basics about programming to even
get to the more interesting parts that I
wanted to focus on but in that initial
part i would lose most of my students
you know by the time I got to the point
that I wanted to really focus on the
students would be you know thinking
about other things so I thought for
example having one one module on that
material and asking the students to
engage with that before coming to the
class would be really helpful and I
experienced what I expected they
they came to class ready to ask
questions the participation was way way
more you know my experience is all
positive but I really want to go beyond
these observations and just anecdotal
evidence we have all this data collected
by the platform about you know the
mastery levels of individual students or
collectively how well they learn the
material i would like to analyze this in
a more scientific way and and i think
this is a place that you can help you
with well one of the great things about
using online learning resources
especially with the oli modules as in
your course is that we have a way to
instrument or collect data on students
as they're learning so we can go to look
at the data online to see what your
students have how they've performed what
they've done and remember we also
created a pretest and a post-test so
that we can compare students performance
before they used your modules to their
performance after they use the modules
this can be really helpful because we
can see how they improved we can also
see the areas where they still could use
some more support and that can help us
refine the modules themselves right I'm
glad you thought of setting up that
pretest because is it you know if I only
told using traditional methods I
wouldn't have remembered to set up that
pretest okay great well maybe we should
take a look at your data so here is the
post test data so you can see the number
of students who completed it in the last
version of this course was used and this
part here shows the percent of students
getting each question correct so you can
really see on some of the items they did
really well yes but there are a few
items where students performance was not
so good so sometimes what is a pretty
efficient strategy is to first target
the questions where students performance
was not so high and see if you based on
your experience teaching in you're not
edge of the subject matter can identify
what might be going on if there was a
misconception or if maybe the material
was confusing or if there's something we
might want to do differently next time
yep so I think we can look at this
question here this is a question that is
what is the value returned by the
following function mm-hmm it's a common
problem students usually get confused
between the function print and return in
return statement so it's actually
expected I try to address this in the in
the class but the fact that it's still
you know it still shows itself in the
post-test makes me think maybe we should
address it even more carefully we could
now what we can do is we can go back to
do you know where in the course this
material would have been addressed right
the initial module okay so this is the
module where that concept would be
introduced right this learning dashboard
page shows students performance and
they're learning during that initial
exposure to that topic so maybe we can
dig in and see is one of these more
relevant to what we just tell just maybe
the part okay nice try that so this
shows us in this area students were
answering questions about defining and
using their own straight line functions
using built-in functions now the
built-in functions would be most likely
okay point so we can click on here and
see students performance on those items
in the module was pretty strong right
except for on this one let's do that
yeah let's view it in the course so
that's an interesting phenomenon that
when they're first learning about this
topic and they're focused on it they
seem to be doing quite well but then
when some time goes on right they need
to retain that conceptual understanding
and transfer maybe to a new situation
like that print function it's a common
challenge for students learning to
retain and transfer what they've learned
so giving the
even more practice and more distributed
practice might be a good strategy so I
could think of injecting similar
questions in other modules yes exactly
so then they learn it here and they're
doing well but then you can come back to
it and check their understanding and
help them practice it and refine it we
could see then if you make that change
if the post-test performance looks
better yeah let's try to do that next
time yeah but in the meantime let's see
what this question holds similarly are
the interaction between print and the
return value of a function yes yes and
that was the one with the worst
performance during the module right
that's right but if you compare how they
did during the module on this problem
with their performance on the post test
post test is slightly bed a little bit
better a little bit so I got actually
important idea that you know coming back
to its more practice is a really good
idea in fact even right around this page
since students were doing not so well on
that item maybe even having some more
instruction or another activity right
there as well as the distributed
practice that's a great idea this is
something we see a lot that when faculty
members are using an online
instructional resource like oli they can
target their instruction to the places
where students need it most right so
that's a specific way we can look to
edit the course and make it better for
next time yeah I'll remember this one
great joy to look at the post-test some
more so if you look at this a particular
learning objective all the students seem
to have done pretty mediocre on that one
right maybe it's me writing the activity
maybe it's not a really well-designed
activity that I should improve on so
what this bar is showing is a lot of
students did not do that much that's why
it's still gray and those students who
did work on activities related to this
learning objective yeah they didn't
excel exact so one reason for that is
just what you're saying that maybe they
did not have enough practice to get
strong right in that skill another
hypothesis is that there were enough
practice opportunities but students were
still struggling so we can click on this
link here and see how many activities of
practice were there and we can
distinguish between those two hypotheses
and it looks like there were only really
three so three practice opportunities
may not be enough for students to master
that skill okay that's good that we
found that out absolutely so if we look
at one of these do you think there would
be some other activities like this that
you could add for practice sergeant ya
next time great